[Music]
linda is with us in gilbert arizona hi
linda welcome to the ramsey show
hi hi what's up hello
what i was calling because i have a
little boy
he's not that little he's 15 years old
uh he's going to be
going to 10th grade um he got his
apartment today
uh so basically in six months he's gonna
be able to drive by himself
um i i drive a bmw
and i'm going to pay it off by next
month
july it shouldn't be paid off um
so i was i would think i should give it
to him
uh or or not his dad passed away
when he like five years ago and i get um
social security for him i get like 13
like 13 40 a month
and i don't know if you guys feel like
uh
like what should i do with that money
should i put it in
in fidelity like that money should be
part of your budget
you spend more than 1300 a month to
raise a child
okay that's part of your budget and then
part of your budget is to raise the
child and part of your budget is to take
care of the child
and think about college and think about
cars and think about those kinds of
things
that money is not separate it's part of
your life
so because that's what i i i'm
planning to do just keep saving saving
the money like
like once i pay this car which is next
month uh
you know first god if he failed my life
um are you doing a monthly budget now
i'm in the start like yeah as soon as i
pay this car
you can start tonight you start tonight
when you get home
go to every dollar and download the
every dollar budget
app it's free to start using or go to
or go do a ramsey plus trial for free
which is even better
you can get the every dollar premium
version to start your budget
all of that and um
you know that'll make all the difference
in the world so you get that going and
then as a part of that you put this 1300
in there as a part of your income you
get take your income in the 1300
and that's what you have to operate your
household with and you pay off the car
as fast as you can possibly pay it off
and then as soon as it's paid off you
pay save up and pay cash for
something for the 16 year old to drive
what year is this beamer
it's uh 2016. and what do you make a
year
i made like around 51 a year yeah and so
this beamer's worth what
i think it's worth 20 grand this one was
like 41.41
something like that you don't give a 16
year old a forty one thousand dollar car
they'll tear it up like that because i
wasn't like basically houston
he needs does he has he has he worked at
all and saved any money
he wants to work but he's only 15 so he
cannot get a job
he can cut grass yeah
he can walk dogs can scoop
up poop they'll pay you for doing all
that
he needs to make some money and you can
put some money with it and let's get him
a little five thousand dollar car
and you pay and you pay cash for it
okay okay you drive the beamer
so you don't think that i should like as
soon as i hit this car like just
sell sell it and then buy another one
that is affordable like with that cash
you could if you want to if you want to
sell it but don't put a 16 year old in a
20 000 car
okay i've had 16 year olds i've raised
several of them
they don't drive well they bump into
stuff
and tear it up and you know your first
car
you know just get something to get them
around you know they'll be proud of it
it'll be fine
and don't talk to me about it's not safe
it's safe
you're talking to a guy who used to
sleep in the back window of the car and
they slam on the brake and we'd roll
down into the floor
so you know and i survived it
at least some people think i did um
we're not sure about the brain damage
part but
but anyway yeah now hon just get him a
little car and if you want to move down
in car in your situation you're welcome
to i don't care
but don't hand a 16 year old
a 15 year old keys to a forty thousand
dollar beamer
no bad plan